IS THE FOCUS.
AS THEY TRY TO FIND THEIR
FOOTING IN THIS RED-HOT ECONOMY
FOR 2020 DEMOCRATS ARE RESORTING
TO HYPERBOLE AND ENDLESS AND
PREDICTABLE PERSONAL ATTACKS.
THEIR INSTINCT IS TO DEMEAN, NOT
DEBATE.
>> ARE WE A NATION THAT TAKES
CHILDREN FROM THEIR PARENTS AT
THE BORDER?
WE DON'T, BUT TRUMP DOES!
>> YOU AGREE THAT HE IS A
RACIST?
>> I DO.
>> WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO IS A
RACIST.
WHO IS A SEXIST, A RELIGIOUS
BIGOT, BUT THAT IS THE TRUTH.
>> Laura: NO IT'S NOT THE
TRUTH.
THIS IS ALL SOUND AND FURY
SIGNIFYING THIS.
IT'S HARD TO SEE THAT ANY OF
THIS AS MOVING THE NEEDLE WITH
INDEPENDENCE OR HEAVEN FORBID
TRUMP VOTERS.
IN THE ABSENCE OF A COMPELLING
AGENDA THE DEMOCRATS ARE LEFT TO
MARINATE IN THEIR OWN RADICALIS
RADICALISM, HOW EXTREME HAVE
THEY BECOME?
THEY NOW BELIEVE THE
CONSTITUTION ALLOWS FOR FULLY
VIABLE INNOCENT BABIES, BOTH
PREBORN AND BORN TO BE KILLED BY
THE MOST GRUESOME MEASURES.
>> THE INFANT WOULD BE
DELIVERED, THE INFANT WOULD BE
KEPT COMFORTABLE.
THE EVENT WOULD BE RESUSCITATED
IF THAT'S WHAT THE MOTHER AND
THE FAMILY DESIRED AND THEN A
DISCUSSION WOULD ENSUE BETWEEN
THE PHYSICIAN AND THE MOTHER.
>> Laura: TO THIS DAY NONE OF
THE 2020 DEMOCRATS --
THERE ARE 23 OF THEM, NONE OF
THEM HAVE CONDEMNED THAT
STATEMENT BY THE STILL SITTING
VIRGINIA GOVERNOR.
IN FACT, THEY ALL SEEM TO BE ON
BOARD WITH WHAT HE SAID.
OF COURSE THEY CALL IT SOMETHING
ELSE, THEY CALL IT WOMEN'S
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH OR A CHOICE.
AS IF WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
PICKING OUT A HANDBAG WHERE A
PAIR OF EARRINGS.
THE ONLY ONES WHO DON'T GET A
CHOICE IN THIS OCCASION ARE THE
BABY AND THE FATHER.
EVER.
>> THERE IS A WELL-FUNDED
ATTACK, COORDINATED BY
RIGHT-WING EXTREMISTS TO DENY
WOMEN THE RIGHT TO CONTROL THEIR
OWN BODIES AND THEIR OWN
FUTURES.
>> I TRUST WOMEN TO DRAW THE
LINE.
>> GOVERNMENTS SHOULD NOT BE I
>> GOVERNMENTS SHOULD NOT BE N
THE BUSINESS OF TELLING A WOMAN
WHAT SHE SHOULD DO WITH HER OWN
BODY.
>> IT SHOULD BE REPEALED AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WOMEN
REGARDLESS OF THEIR INCOME LEVEL
HAVE A BASIC RIGHT TO
REPRODUCTIVE CARE.
>> Laura: LOTS OF EUPHEMISMS.
RATHER THAN APPEAL TO
MIDDLE-CLASS AMERICA, THEY
DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO OUT
METAL ONE ANOTHER IN THE RADICAL
OLYMPICS AND NOT JUST ON THE
ISSUE OF ABORTION BUT ON A LOT
OF OTHER CULTURAL ISSUES AS WELL
SUCH AS GENDER IDENTIFICATION.
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT LAST WEEK.
THIS RADICAL SOCIAL AGENDA WAS
ORIGINALLY DEVELOPED AND
CONCEIVED IN THE ACADEMY AND IT
WAS MEANT TO UP AND THE OLD
ORDER, THE TRADITIONAL FAMILY
STRUCTURE THAT HAS BEEN AT THE
CORE OF EVERY MAJOR CIVILIZATION
THROUGHOUT HISTORY.
THIS NEW WORLD ORDER, THIS NEW
WORLD VIEW WAS THEN MAINSTREAMED
BY THE POPULAR CULTURE AND
EVENTUALLY EMBRACED BY DEMOCRATS
AND SOME REPUBLICANS.
IT HAS NOW BECOME A NEW
POLITICALLY CORRECT ORTHODOXY.
IT'S EXTREMIST AND TOTALLY
UNYIELDING.
ON ISSUES SUCH AS GENDER AND
ABORTION ITS INHERENCE AREN'T
VICIOUS.
IF YOU DARE DISAGREE WITH THEIR
WORLDVIEW THEY BELIEVE THAT YOU
SHOULD LOSE YOUR JOB AND FRANKLY
BE BANISHED FOREVER FROM THE
PUBLIC SQUARE AND I'M NOT
EXAGGERATING.
IT WASN'T ALWAYS THIS WAY.
THIS WAS BARACK OBAMA BACK IN
2008.
>> DEFINE MARRIAGE?
>> I BELIEVE THAT MARRIAGE IS
THE UNION BETWEEN A MAN AND A
WOMAN, NOT FOR ME AS A
CHRISTIAN --
[APPLAUSE]
FOR ME AS A QUESTION IT'S A
SACRED UNION.
>> Laura: AND HIS BOOK HE
REVEALED THAT BARACK OBAMA WAS
LONG WHEN HE SAID THAT, HE WAS
BASICALLY SAYING THAT TO GET
ELECTED AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
INVOLVED, THAT IS FOR SURE.
JUST LIKE NOW WE KNOW THAT
HILLARY CLINTON WAS LYING WHEN
SHE SAID THIS.
>> WE CAN SUPPORT A WOMAN'S
RIGHT TO CHOOSE THAT MAKES
ABORTION SAFE, LEGAL, AND RARE,
AND REDUCES THE NUMBER OF
ABORTIONS.
>> Laura: WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
RARE PART?
A MILLION A YEAR.
AT LEAST NOW THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
AMASSED THEMSELVES, IT'S KIND OF
LIBERATING.
THE APHORISMS ABOUT A WOMAN'S
CHOICE DON'T REALLY WORK
ANYMORE,
NOW THAT THE LEGISLATOR GAVE
ITSELF A STANDING OVATION AS
THEY WENT FAR BEYOND THE OLD
LANGUAGE AND LEGALIZED
INFANTICIDE.
MUCH OF THE COUNTRY IS BECOMING
MORE PRO-LIFE, HE WOULD NEVER
KNOW IT BY HIM READING THE
NEWSPAPERS, PARTICULARLY IN THE
LATER STAGES OF
PREGNANCY.
THIS HAS BEEN THE CASE FOR SOME
TIME.
DEMOCRATS THINK THAT THEY KNEW
ALABAMA LAW THAT OUTLAWS MOST
ABORTIONS, THEY THINK IT GIVES
THEM A HUGE OPENING IN 2020.
THEY'D BEEN LOOKING FOR AN
OPENING.
AS USUAL THEY MISREAD THE
COUNTRY.
ALABAMA DIDN'T PASS THE LAW TO
SCORE POLITICAL POINTS,
ALABAMIANS PASSED THE LAW
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE THAT THEY
WERE SAVING THE LIVES OF
INNOCENT BABIES.
FOR CHRISTIANS AND OTHERS WHO
BELIEVE ABORTIONS IS THE TAKING
OF AN INNOCENT LIFE, NO AMOUNT
OF VILIFICATION BY HOLLYWOOD,
NEWS MEDIA, ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ, ANYBODY WILL
CHANGE THEIR MORAL DETERMINATIO
DETERMINATION.
TRUMP BY THE WAY RECOGNIZES THIS
AND 2016.
>> IF YOU GO WITH WHAT HILLARY
IS SAYING IN THE NINTH MONTH YOU
CAN TAKE THE BABY AND RIP THE
BABY OUT OF THE WOMB OF THE
MOTHER JUST PRIOR TO THE BIRTH
OF THE BABY.
YOU CAN SAY THAT THAT IS OKAY
AND HILLARY CAN SAY THAT THAT IS
OKAY, BUT IT'S NOT OKAY WITH ME.
>> Laura: AND NORMAL PRESS
SETTINGS DEMOCRATS ARE RARELY
ASKED UNCOMFORTABLE SPECIFICS
ON WHAT IT IS, ABORTION.
THEY ARE USUALLY ABLE TO SKATE
THROUGH WITH GENERALITIES THAT
WE HAVE HEARD A THOUSAND TIMES
BEFORE.
TRUMP I DON'T THINK LET'S HIS
OPPONENTS GLIDE BY SO EASILY.
SECOND, REGARDING THOSE
SO-CALLED EXPERTS WHO THINK THE
SOCIAL ISSUES WILL HURT
REPUBLICAN PROSPECTS, I WILL
REMIND YOU THAT MANY OF THE SAME
EXPERTS HAVE BEEN SAYING THE
SAME THINGS SINCE ROE V. WADE
WAS DECIDED.
REMEMBER, THESE ARE MANY OF THE
SAME PEOPLE WHO SAID TRUMP WOULD
LOSE AND 2016 FOR THE SAME
REASON.
>> HAS COMMENTS ON ABORTION AND
VOWED TO SELECT SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES WHO WILL OPPOSE ROE V.
WADE.
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS NO IDEA
ABOUT WOMEN AND WOMEN'S HEALTH.